right the next one I know it's a bit
close to your heart obviously you're a
good power a certain person on that
board and he works for him now as well
delious you going to do
your you lot shouldn't have done this
that's naughty you shouldn't have done
this random generator not random
generator random generator a producer
knew what it was doing and he did their
job perfectly 100% this is they cre this
is this is I don't want to swear but
this this is the go on sport Bible and
we're deciding once and for all who is
is the greatest England men's player of
all time we ped the sport bubble
audience ask him who they think is the
greatest and the top answers are on this
board each round you're knocking one
name out and one name through and if you
can't agree we're going back to the pole
we'll do that until just one name's left
and we'll Crown who is the greatest of
all time so the first bracket we're
going to have David Beckham versus Peter
shilon yeah so K do you want to kick us
off David Beckham yeah can p it anywhere
as soon as you get a COR if as soon as
you get a corner you're actually looking
at a goal really David Beckham in terms
of dead bull specialist yeah I know we
got the wardes now we've had the janinos
we've had some Specialists right but
he's the original let's let's not let's
not let's not mess us up and he doesn't
get the credit he deserves when you
speak to xros they say just how good he
is one touch in possession getting about
the pitch he wasn't just a free kick
Merchant like and if we're talking about
iconic footballers Rockstar footballers
yes we talk about Off Pitch stuff bro he
married a spice gu I know this is not
probably football and stuff but it's
is bro and he went and one of the main
Spice Girls yeah yeah and he bro he was
in the audience for you know the wedding
the king you know like the king and
queen wedding he's there they bring him
in yeah this guy's a whole legend he has
to be there and even after football go
look he bought a whole team called Miami
and look what Messi's doing because he's
David Beckham he sign he's signed one of
the goats that makes him a goat already
it does it does it's David beckh it's
David beckam but honor mention to pet sh
what about him I don't know this is a
big guy he's the leading all time cap
holder 125 appearances for England
Rooney 120 he a five behind him changes
nothing it doesn't it doesn't right it
doesn't so I feel like we're pretty
unanimous on this one you guys are happy
with that absolutely absolutely yeah so
without further Ado can you please put
through David Beckham there you go sorry
Shon you're not sorry not at all yeah
right Wayne Rooney versus Harry Kane do
you want to start off flex I'm try to do
this without being biased and without
even giving my answer away for this
whole thing actually
but Wayne Rooney no just put it back not
yet cool all right see I should have
hold it we got we got fans from all
overwatching yeah yeah yeah yeah let's
put some respect on just put respect on
that yeah um Harry Kane is a fantastic
player but if you're talking about
serial winner if you're talking about
ability if you're talking about all
round game if you're talking about
sacrificing aspects of his game to allow
others to come through Rooney had to
reinvent himself so many times through a
Manchester United um era whether it was
TZ coming in and Ronaldo coming in or
bbov coming in he's always there this is
the guy remember when we was praying for
his metat tassle yeah remember as a as a
nation we didn't I didn't know nothing
I'm not a doctor nothing about X-rays I
was looking at x-ray all that where is
that's where did I find it in his foot
that's actually quite important people
come on and we're like oh man I hope
he's going to be fine this kid yeah he
um jumped onto the scene and he could
put the pressure of England on his back
now Kane he's been good he has has been
good but that's he's just different but
he's overtaken him now hasn't he Harry
Kane and we do have to put respect on
that he has overtaken him as England's
all8 goals to Rooney's 53 don't say it
changes nothing because it does count
for something cuz for England Harry Kane
has been the man he has you can't you
can't doubt though I just think player
for player pound for pound 100 Rooney
when it comes down to it whether it's
International lynchpin whether it's at
Club level just as a footballer in
general I'm going Wayne Rooney
absolutely all day on that note next
through a
big next one then Paul skulls versus
gascoin that that Golden Era of Lampard
Gerard
SKS skulls was kind of like the ugly
duckling and I don't mean that in a bad
way cuz I love SK say that cuz he's
Ginger I'm not saying that cuz he
Ginger I'm not saying that right love
love love to every Ginger person around
the world however Paul skulls was put on
the left Paul skulls was put on the
right sometimes he put in it never
really fit now did skulls give me iconic
England moments just a back sh did Gaza
give me iconic England moments we
flipped over Henry's head Colin Henry
thought he was in braveart he just
tricked over his head like nothing Loess
monster bro he said no no no no 96 at
over are you crazy I remember that you
know what I understand I understand it
but this this makes me sick that's
insane what we're about to do kind of
want you to do it cuz I don't want to
yeah it's your side I got I got told
instructions don't cross the board don't
cross the board mate that's his cop out
that's right come on Kg without further
Ado man you going to put I'm so
sorry that's crazy that's I don't even
believe this though I'm doing this out
of just getting pushed into it bro like
go kg Flex you feel like you pushed him
into that one no I feel like I made a
good I feel like I'm trying to be as
unbiased as
we got to put respect on people like G
big respect for
England was playing our position I feel
like the people who put this together
maybe put skull in the wrong bit who was
in charge of that I want to know who it
was it was a random generator yeah oh I
bet it was well next one Alan Shear
versus Gary linar don't get it twisted
Alan Shar was what Harry Kane is now
that's that is it that's why he has the
record in the Premier League and for
England as well Talisman he was the
reason why Andy Cole couldn't really get
games Les Ferdinand couldn't really get
games Ted Sharon because this guy is
that you know how good he is this guy's
so good that he knew he was going to
score and his celebration just had to be
really simple yeah it was me get one of
those it was me is that cuz you know
when you're rubbish back flips you go
crazy cuz you can you can use up a lot
of cardio in them moments he said bro
chances of me scoring is very high
simple settings you think you think
doing you know the r k just rolling too
much get out here football IQ he's not
trying to waste energy we being honest
yeah it's actually more is Shar man yeah
I like the Shar one I told you this side
is really easy when it it's the next
round that gets a bit tight yeah ites
all right and sure without further Ado
please moveing forward yeah that shake
up very nicely on that side let's go on
to this side of the draw we have got
Steven Gerard versus John Barnes easy
easy and you what I want you to do right
now yeah is think it NOS it is easy it's
not it
is I know you're not saying what I think
you're saying this is easy I've got I've
got an honor mention but this is easy
are you going to say John BNS is not
going to get through I've got I've got
who my choic is and I've got an honor
mention I'm half Jamaican right well
done I'm half Jamaican yeah yeah go he
means a lot to me he means a lot to me
you're going to snake him he means a lot
to me right he did a lot for the game he
was an iconic
midfielder but Steven jeral wait black
people down a w they're crying right now
my n's going to be watching this
year as first generation Jamaican coming
over yeah she's going to be watching
this year because I feel like every
Caribbean person loved John bares at a
time Liverpool but but but 100% but as a
player unbelievable powerful could run
through brick walls Glide class players
like they weren't
there Gerard though it's different
different forget the man doing that this
not this again they're both Liverpool
bro there's a guy I think even John
Barnes would agree that's how that is BR
he even raps bro he's got the
song Ted he's Jamaican and he went and
got that no but look at the Rhythm
though you crazy it was
need I got to bully my hand you know if
he went to Carnival and done that he'
get run
out wait hold on all right to create
difficulty degree of difficulty playing
in a mad time yeah he played in one of
Liverpool's best beat are in these guys
bro I don't care won the league twice
bro are you know fa Cups he's won that
he's won that he's a big bro this degree
of difficulty I I agree I turning up
yeah you have to take a degree of
difficulty bro I love John BNS well not
clearly enough but not enough cuz right
not enough to let my heart rule my head
you're just doing the Liverpool thing
you're thinking about they're both
Liverpool now I'm saying you're thinking
about what Liverpool did champions
league and Mr Gerard all all action
Liverpool but I'm saying this guy like
he so you're saying he done more for
England he
done yeah in what sense in what in what
sense though in what sense did he do
more for England I'm saying again he
that's the golden generation there's a
wait hold on the golden generation yeah
Gerard Beckham there was that one that
was the probably the best team England's
ever assembled they did nothing and he
him those two are the kings of it when
we had we've had Arguments for and
people still trying to work it out like
The Da Vinci Code how do we put um
Gerard and Lampard in the same team it's
been the argument forever that's the
manager's faults put it on them put no
put it on Steve MC his little Broly
that's not that's not that's not to us
now you know chill out oh yeah I love
Steve
Steve Steve Steve I've got a rly for you
don't again if you want to argue about
the manager getting it wrong well the
managers misus this guy so 100% but that
that's what I'm saying don't use that as
a chance to say that this guy should not
be in the go conversation I'm putting
gerro yeah I was about to say I'm glad
to push you I'm going Gerard ger I'm
getting John B but I don't like it I
think we need look we can go to the
audience
John Barnes 2.25% of the vote okay
Steven Gerard 3% of the vote so Steven
Gerald wins just just it's tight so
again it was tight football brain M it's
tib you happy with that you happy with
that yes I'm not happy
yesy you're not clearly not happy about
this so we have got Raheem Sterling
versus Frank Lampard go and let down
Jamaica again you're not getting your
yourled J is done you ain't getting in
you see Sterling yeah go I think don't
say this stuff no no here you go
Sterling is the most disrespected player
okay in English History you going to
disrespect him now though I'm not I'm
not I'm biging him up I'm giving him his
flowers at times where England have
needed a spark at times where England
have needed goals yeah he's always
overlooked I remember in the Euros
where's Jack GIS why is Jack Gus not
starting Sterling when Kan wasn't doing
anything when Gus was on the bench he
single-handedly got us through the group
stages into the into the Knockouts and
then he scored again in The Knockouts as
well completely massive player for
England Frank Lampard part of the failed
Midfield fraternity that you spoke about
where does he fit in what does he do at
Club level cool but for England and
impact for England powerful it is Raheem
Sterling are you going to put him in of
course I
am
yeah laughing now so wait I like you
know I can't with what you what you said
on the England thing I I I saw it I
watched it I was there yeah he's up
there as one of the best well clearly
he's up there as one of the best England
I'm glad I'm actually glad he's on this
ball because honestly I think Raheem
Sterling gets disrespected all the time
for England he was fantastic lamp listen
lampard's a serious player he's a great
player he's one of the greatest goal
scorer midfielders yeah ever as well he
scored 29 times in 106 appearances and
Sterling scored 20 in 82 only a little
bit behind him there you go made it
easier there go put him through Sterling
most dis respected guy and you know what
as well the audience also agreed with
you Sterling 4% of the V you laugh at me
but I was there I was there you to say
sorry you need to say sorry to me say
I'm not a motive driven I'm driven by
this wait I haven't done anything and
they agree with me no when you said your
argument I said you know what I like
that the audience has decided so a the
AUD decided so me argue with them right
the next one know it's a bit close to
your heart obviously you're a good power
a certain person on that board so we got
next he works for him now as well
hilarious you going to do to your
boss this is where this is no this is
where your boss wants to see leadership
okay so we have car of course real F Now
versus Bobby Charlton and as United fans
this must hurt this is I hate when I
came in you saw my face I said you
shouldn't have done this that's naughty
you shouldn't have done this random
generator not random generator randomat
a producer knew what he was doing and he
did their job perfectly 100% this this
is this is I don't want to swear about
this
is
all right who want to start us off flex
Rio is the best center off of that
generation yeah he is like in terms of
making defending cool in in terms of
playing out from the back being that
roll Royce that that term that we put
out so flippantly now Cela seems to have
it varane's had it his whole career this
is the original original so he's unreal
with what Rio's done in the game with
what a leader he was you're talking
about someone who won the World Cup with
England the guy won the balandor in the
same season he won the World Cup and I
was and that was english's greatest ever
team that's the only thing we've ever
done on the international stage and this
man was integral to it so how can I then
say in the goat conversation for England
an impact on England that Bobby Char is
not there you already know you see him
you see Fergy you see Bobby you're like
wow you know what I mean you understand
Heritage everything that we talk
everything that is good about United and
England he's there this this is this is
um
emotive as well but some years before
that Bobby Charon experienced a crash
with the Busby babes and came out on the
other end of that and to rebuild his
career and reach the Pinnacle of winning
you done it yeah of winning the World
Cup and winning the bonor you done it
after what happened
in Don't Take again people could say
that's the motive cuz it's a club thing
but I'm bringing it into the
international stage because he's managed
to get up there after going through that
after doing that yeah right final one
yes we have got Bobby Moore versus
Ashley Cole now we got to like we got to
put some respect on cashley as well cuz
like the guy here as as a left back
probably one of the greatest to do it
not probably probably like I want to say
one of the greatest to do it so have
English left back absolutely there's we
have we replaced him at in at the
English level this guy on the
international scene you could trust in
Ashley Cole so again the same way we
should put respect on it's different
with the Sterling thing but this is a
we're talking about a very good left
back and for me to to say that as played
for Arsenal and that's his good Peak
some of his Peak gears were for Arsenal
to move one Chelsea like he's up there
this but then we know what we're talking
about this guy Eng no that's why I just
no I just thing
that's mention thing you know when you
say yeah big up to you what be more
listen he was a he's a West Ham Legend
all right and captained England yeah to
World Cup that iconic picture of him on
the shoulders with the I think that's
that picture that's yeah lives on
forever you're talking about what you've
done for England well put that put that
down you know when they say when your
career is done put your medals down tell
us your stories Captain World Cup man
yeah no one's done it since what did you
do in your career yeah nothing could top
it won a Champions League so but did you
win a you what I mean like it you can't
Eclipse that yeah so it's got to be Bob
more all right without further Ado
popping through I know what I'm doing in
the next round
though just wait right let's go back to
kg's side of the draw Beckham versus
Rooney
I would say
honestly this is not it's not that
difficult I think in terms of the nation
and him getting us there you can't leave
Beckham out I love Rooney I love Rooney
but then we
what are you going to do that yeah
you're not going to put you're not going
to make an argument for Wayne Rooney to
get past us I love I love Wayne Rooney
but then I think again it's like until
the other day our alltime top goal
scorer and man united at the same time
you're not going to talk about we're not
talking about man united man united for
England yeah I've already stopped as
soon as I couldn't get this guy in
anymore I said I it's an England thing
then we're just talking about England
we're not talking about man united and
he was England's greatest ever goal
scorer I hear it but still then go why
it's Roy I just like how it said why
because he burst onto the scene as a kid
and got into the England team super
early and the things that he was able to
do in terms of all over the pitch go to
war get up and down the pitch score
goals he was our leading ever goal
scorer no about seriously Beckham is so
iconic for England as well and I
remember in terms of again degree of
difficulty you have to take that into
advant you played in the golden
generation like you say and so did and
so you had to get us through though it
was on his shoulders and you know again
he was he was vilified and then he went
from villain to Hero Let's that's a
that's a It's A Cinderella Story It's A
Cinderella Story this is this is up
there this is up there do you want to
put it down to the audience yeah we're
going to have to cuz I'm saying Rooney
you're saying Beckham we have to cuz we
disagree we don't though it's a
democracy
that's what this is for what I'm seeing
no let's make it interesting put it to a
vote L they agree with well look um
Rooney had twice as many votes as
Beckham unfortun I told you I think you
just go with the go with what we feel
bro like I am Hey listen even though you
not employing me and I'm you not the
reason why I'm here yeah I don't
like you don't agree don't agree don't
blame us blame
I'm actually talking a right now I'm
talking to all the audience in the
comment section everywhere every for
democracy when democracy speaks you act
like this yeah yeah yeah can't stand
people yeah don't agree don't right next
up we have got gascoin versus
Shir this is tough you're talking about
an absolute goal machine of this
generation as well longevity as well
scored a lot of goals for England yeah
but in terms of the moments the reason
why I put Gaza through the first time
yeah he gave me that feeling he gave me
that moment he gave me
that that Euphoria yeah I'm still salty
about a lot of things oh come on come on
no I am but it's all right I've over it
but I'm I'm pissed about a lot of things
but this guy here he's still legendary
though we can't we can't mess around
with Alan Shir gaza's got more ability
in his left boot than Alan Shir has in
his whole armoring
facts this is crazy facts as a player as
ability wise So based on ability you
want to put Gaza through yeah okay yeah
kg you know characters you know what I'm
going to go to the audience oh oh oh now
you believe in what they say no you're a
cop don't let him do that I swear I knew
you were going to do that so I got I'm
ready I'm ready I'm playing AUD audience
well look Paul gascoin 5% of the vote
Alan sheir with 2% of the vote it's easy
mate you go t there you
go right okay let's go back to your side
of the draw yes we're going to go Gerard
versus Sterling Gerard yeah
in English he's he's Gerard has got to
be in this conversation he does he does
you can't just dismiss it you can't
because Gerard I know you keep you keep
your argument is that the failed
midfielder could never do anything yeah
don't tell me what my argument that's it
was but the ab but the but the ability
of this guy yeah to do to do things to
do things in a shirt for England when
some people couldn't do it it weighed
heavy it did weigh heavy and he's clutch
he is clutch but
again thank you I I wanted to know
you're going I was wait I but yes good
again disrespectful this isn't to do
with Club level this is strictly England
and again he has to go ahead and set a
Gerard for me because I I can't look I
can't look past when it just didn't work
with Lampard Gerard's goals I still feel
that Sterling has done more in an
England shirt than Geral has I think
Sterling has done more in Eng yeah the
impact England do it all right do it
without further Ado get St through there
and that's the probably the last step
you'll take
though Bobby Char versus Bobby
Moore Bobby which
one sh Bobby
joh yeah she didn't
know I was like obviously the one you
know I want did it um no obviously he's
not the captive but that don't matter in
terms of like um you can't ask me what
if I one bro I was there like when when
you lifted it I was with you bro you
know what I'm saying so um you want the
bendor mate bonor like again had a great
career these guys are both they can re
like if they're ever having a chat you
know what that chat sounds like
different Lev we were there we the last
we're the last they don't even have that
cup no more they made a new one more as
well had two assists in the World Cup
finals from Center half from Center back
to
TI impact man no you can't to be no no
no no no don't let the man united agenda
absolutely agenda let it in allow it bro
allow it Bobby Br just allow it just
allow it we don't have to do that all
right we don't have to well we're
disagreeing so we know where it's going
to go no no what are you doing we don't
have to do this bro as you bro listen
look look I like it we have to we have
to do what's right I'm telling you right
now they will respect us for this do it
I think I think that I think the people
at home know that it's what we want okay
you want we'll look that in yeah yeah
but I'll tell you the votes Bobby Mo got
6% of the vote Bobby TR got
seven finally got look what you did look
what you did finally come right
semi-final time Rooney versus
gascoin you know what that is is that it
is that
just and you know he he crawled to this
guy could run so we can't we we can't
forget like but then him England at the
Young and you you think how can a nation
be relying on this young player in the
total 90s remember the night the the
boots in that Rooney I'm telling you
like it was a special time watching that
and thinking bloody hell how is this guy
so good played Fearless aggression and
they and they he led you know that was a
big moment for him as well that the the
nation could almost rely on Rooney and
then we have to talk about longevity I
love Gaza but in terms of to apply
himself for that long and be one of the
top players of the game for for a long
period it's Rooney man simple simple
actually you know I'm so proud of us
bro it's look what's happened look
what's happened you know what's about to
happen in it I'm so proud of us this
done there only one ever no no cuz look
what we've done you already know what's
happening
in we're winners anyway amazing right
final semi-final Sterling versus
don't even take
the Raheem went school around the corner
for
me he grew up with Wembley so did I I
think he went to Copeland High School l
a corner from where I used to live um
but I think this is where raheem's
Journey comes to an end it comes to an
end but then when it comes to put your
medals on the table what have you done
rahee will say Bobby what have you done
so we're happy with that yeah happy with
that we're happy with that to us the
honors you and
I get
out I could not have predicted this at
the beginning I could not have seen this
coming whatsoever happy right let's get
into it the big fin of to Crown the
greatest of all time Wayne Rooney versus
Bobby Charon you know what I'm going to
be honest I just want it to be I want it
to be Rooney cuz from from the start to
me Rooney is the best English player of
all time ever that we've ever had ever I
agree in our era but then in the other
era like when they were successful I
know that's what I mean you know what
happened yeah there's a crown for a
reason and you can't Crown these guys if
they've never brought Joy to the nation
yeah I wasn't there and even was I but
then I heard it was great ultimately it
is you two deciding so I think you we're
not doing we're not taking we're not
going to do that bro do the right thing
what how's the celebration bro he
basically did Rock he basically did
Jay-Z when it he didn't mean
to Bro remember all the Shrek toys that
sold as well cuz he that was again for
clash and selling merch as well but
we're not that's not this about it's not
based on mer about you know what I've
I've used the metric we've used the
metric properly of what you've done in
the greatest thing in an England shirt
so it does have to be Bobby CH but I
want it to be
rud quickly I want to put I just want to
put it out there Wayne Rooney scored
more goals than Bobby CH for doesn't
matter doesn't matter just winning is
important it has to it has to supersede
everything and this guy
you know Bobby CH stand bro yeah I I I
do I do think you're right the more I
thinking about it cuz when you think
about like I said before one of the
stages back here of rebuilding his life
probably didn't even know if he was
going to be able to play football again
lost a whole lot of people and I'm not
trying to go down to sympathy roow but
the mental strength that that needs to
to hit the heights again in your career
for club and Country one big things of
man won the European Cup 10 years later
with man united in 68 and then managed
to win that in' 66 degree of difficulty
degree of difficulty you have to take
that to yeah looks like you both decided
abolutely so let's Crown wow look at
that Bobby
yes let me put this right here bro you
trying to suggest that ronal is the best
player in the world right now is not
even the best player in the league you
say Ron's the best player in the right
now when when we talk about great
players Salah can't talk Ronaldo he
can't salak to Ronaldo